hello and welcome back to steampunks
GameSpot's pc focus show we talk about
PC and all the issues that PC game is
kind of worried about and this week lots
of big games are coming out and towards
the end of this year yeah and there's
always the big question of like there's
a big game coming out I know I want to
play it do i preorder it
that's the question they do you put out
a game did you preorder games it's
obviously a big question that's you've
all been asking for a long time yeah I
mean the argument is between do you want
to make sure you're getting your hands
on those bonuses which is of course
their marketing incentive to make sure
you preorder the game what do you want
to wait for the reviews wait for the
zeitgeist and give up the opportunity to
access those so you can get a better
view of what the game is or do you not
mind either way and you just know you're
gonna play it so you just pick it up
yeah at I'm a sneaky thing because I'm
obviously originally pre-orders existed
because games came in a physical format
and there are only so many games you
could get so you had to make sure you
had to preorder in so you could get it
on day one and make sure you had a copy
to play yeah obviously that doesn't
matter anymore especially with PC
because it's all digital
yeah so those sneaky or pre-order
bonuses that sometimes they just don't
even matter and sometimes they're you
know they're really worthwhile yeah it's
kind of like oh this dilemma of like do
I do it do I want the content like I
want the game and I knowing them I like
the game I want to have all the stuff
right
I think one of the more interesting
things now is what we're saying to come
in pre-order bonuses so one of the
massive things that's happening is betas
so fallout 76 you need to preorder it if
you want to get in the beta which is of
course something people want to get
their hands on especially with a game
like fallout 76 well we don't really
know what to expect at this stage people
really want to play that beta to find
out if it's something they want to play
so the other side of the coin of things
that happening is because it's not a
stock thing people are pre-ordering
these games to get access to the beta
and some of them are playing the beta
finding out if it's their thing and
cancelling it if it's not yeah I mean
that's the one advantage about pre-order
except on PC especially understand
because team has a steam refund process
you can't really do that on consoles but
yeah betas are kind of like one of the
better incentives yeah pre-order I guess
though it's still kind of still
sucks yeah I mean obviously a lot of
games have open made it as well so you
don't necessarily need to have that and
obviously if you're if you're a
developer and you want a lot of people
to stress test your multiplayer servers
why not just make it open why make it a
pre-order incentive you know that
doesn't make sense except if you want
people to buy your game and one of the
more interesting examples of getting
access to a beta which wasn't even the
beta for the game was if you pre-ordered
crackdown you got access to the halo 3
beta which everyone wanted into and some
of you that's the reason the crackdown
series got so popular so of course
there's been the preorder boycott lately
when people have picked up games that
ended up being disappointing I guess we
can include Mass Effect 3 and no man's
sky into the spectrometer I think it was
alright those kind of games that people
were just really disappointed it was
like top shelf top price games people
didn't like and so so went the movement
of the hash tag stuff reordering games
yeah I mean I preorder a lot of games I
buy a lot of games and you know when you
buy a lot of games you want to save a
little bit of money and obviously one of
the pre incentives pre-order is you say
about 10% yes if I know if I think I'm
gonna like something you know I won't do
that
foolishly I will admit and I think a lot
of the stuff I have actually been burned
on things are actually like EA origin
games like Mass Effect Andromeda was a
big one there are even some cases where
like i pre-ordered a game from a
publisher or developer day no I really
really loved and I really wanted to
support them but I was a little
disappointed so drastic what evolution
was another recent one because I
freaking loved planet coaster
I love frontier but have been in a lot
of cases where I have been really
grateful that i pre-ordered the game and
I got all the bonuses that I wanted it
ya know I really loved it I mean this
isn't a PC example but you know i
pre-ordered Red Dead Redemption too
because I think I know that's gonna be a
pretty good game I think somebody's safe
bet yeah I really hope so cuz
PlayStation doesn't let you reform
pre-orders yeah yeah how about you I
think sometimes you gotta take the
gamble on that stuff the game I really
got burned by was watchdogs oh oh me too
watchdogs the marketing was so good and
they're getting suckered by the
marketing yeah it's such a gut punch in
the end it when it doesn't live up to
your expectations yeah I got an hour
into that game and
just like kids I was still pumped like
even upon starting it and getting into
it I was like okay this isn't quite what
I wanted it to be but I was still pumped
I got an hour and I was just I'm
straight-up not enjoying this
and there goes I mean in Australia that
was $100 game ok crap obviously up to
mention Kickstarter's because you and I
both kick-started a lot of kicks out of
the decks especially in the heyday of
Kickstarter back in 2010 22 2012 where a
lot of really big retro revivals we're
happening and you know I still like
projects I backed in 2012 that still
haven't come out yet
and I'm putting a lot of faith into that
you know for the most but a lot of them
have being really good you know Banner
Saga worked out really well the Double
Fine thing that was you know had mixed
reviews but I really enjoyed it
like working-age yeah it's interesting
though because with Kickstarter you you
putting your dollars behind it for
another reason as well is because you
want it to be made in the first place I
kick-started dreamfall chapters I'm when
that game came out and I put I don't
want to stay but it's like I for
hundreds of dollars behind that game so
so excited about it for my like favorite
series of all time and still don't have
the physical addition I kick-started
that in 2012 I think they're sending
them soon but yeah it's just one of
those things I think it makes a
difference when you pre-order if you had
that faith in the developer you had that
faith in the series I think I would be
more hesitant to ever preorder anything
like I did with watchdogs when I was
doing it based on a marketing campaign
and not based on having a pre-existing
love for a developer awesome yeah that's
true I mean in my case was the ones I'm
still waiting on the project and the
guys who made Space Quest and you know I
you know I love those Souza's when I was
a kid you know if it ends up not being
great you know that's not gonna be the
biggest bummer because I only backed it
for like 20 or 30 dollars but I just
wanted them to know that hey people will
still want immature games like the game
he used to make because that's really
important to a lot of people I think
being in the position that we are in we
get more of an insight what a game might
be like the Furcal yeah so I'm a little
more careful on that obviously that's
really hard for you know your average
gamer to do but if the biggest incentive
for you is money and like saving a bit
of money on the pre-order like it is to
me it is like kind of nice to know that
Steam obviously has launched discounts
as well as better discounts and they are
often the same I also think another
reason
is your the best gauge of whether or not
you're going to be into again because
yes you can wait till reviews come out
and stuff but the reviews I guys isn't
necessarily reflective of how much
you're gonna personally enjoy a day and
I've had several favorite games
including Might & Magic 10 that came out
a few years back my favorite game of the
year it got like six it's across the
board yes I personally really liked it
and it came from a series that I had a
lot of nostalgia for me and I already
had a lot of love for yeah I think we've
all had that situation where a game has
been it reviewed very poorly but I've
friggin loved it you know and that's
another whole other conversation in
itself but you know if you think you're
gonna like something then maybe you will
and you know and if you don't there's
always steam reforming yeah don't abuse
it you should support the developers as
well if someone's making something that
you like I'm very happy to give them my
money yeah that's just what we think but
do let us know down in that comment
section what you guys think of pre old
is you do it do you not and do let us
know why also thank you so much for your
comments on last week's episode about
remasters enjoyed seeing the general
vibe that when Remos is a clearly a
cash-in yeah you're not happy with it
but if it's if it is to like revive like
an old school game that like wouldn't
exist without the remaster and just like
to keep it in in the in the gaming field
so that younger generations can play it
and stuff that makes it a really good
thing yeah I think the sentiment was
mainly on onboard with sort of what we
thought I mean yeah you can tell and
when a good'n remaster happens you know
people are pretty thankful for that
yeah when like Dark Souls ships out
games the windows live out of its thing
you know people are happy you know
that's great yeah so let us know about
your thoughts about pre-orders and tell
us all that stuff and let me know the
worst pre-order you ever got burned by
please do
[Music]
you